All right, guys, so here is example number two.
So basically, there are some other things
that wanna throw it out.
So when you are extremely bullish or bearish,
every auto blog, or I would say demand zone
could be a POI, and you can look for confirmation entries
from those POIs.
So for example, right here, you can see we are bullish
right here.
We're looking at GBPUSD, and there is this auto blog
right here, right?
And the thing that I was talking about,
how to combine DXY with this strategy.
So when you have a institutional support level
or auto blog here and price comes back into this auto blog,
when price comes back to this auto blog on GBPUSD,
you go to DXY and see if price
is also at the resistance level of some sort, okay?
So as you know, the DXY chart is inverse to this.
So if GBPUSD is going up, DXY is gonna go down.
Simple, right?
But around here, when price reaches this auto blog,
and on DXY, price at the same time, okay?
Not at the same time, but if it's at the resistance level,
right?
Let's assume that this is DXY and this is auto blog,
and price is here at the auto blog, right?
And also on GBPUSD, price is at the support level
or bullish auto blog, right?
Then that is a confluence that you can use.
So in other words, in simple words,
GBPUSD slash EuroUSD slash AUDZ.
If they are at some OB
and at this, if one of these are at some OB
and at the same time, DXY is at some OB as well.
So OB could be a resistance or support level.
So generally, auto blogs are support and resistance levels,
okay?
So that's why I'm calling them support and resistance.
So let's assume that GBP and EuroUSD,
both of them hit the auto blog right here, okay?
Or I would say that GBPUSD hits the auto blog,
EuroUSD does not hit the auto blog,
and DXY also is at some sort of resistance level, right?
Then you should trade a GBPUSD.
If EuroUSD hits the auto blog, right?
And GBPUSD and AUDUSD do not hit the auto blog,
which is right here, do not touch the auto blog.
And at the same time, DXY is at the resistance level,
it is touching the resistance or an auto blog here,
which could be actually this, my bad, right?
Then you wanna trade EuroUSD.
I know this is sounding a little bit complicated,
but it is not if you really focus on that,
what I'm trying to say.
And let's say that GBUSD and EuroUSD both
are not touching the auto blog,
and they are somewhere around here, right?
And AUDUSD has already touched this auto blog,
and at the same time, DXY is also at some sort
of resistance level, then that, my friend,
is the sign that you should be trading AUDUSD.
I hope that is clear, guys.
So let me show you how this works.
So we know that we are bullish, right?
Price going up, we have this auto blog right here.
So I dropped down to 15 minute time for him.
Look for a shift in market structure.
There you go, we have a market structure shift,
and this right here, okay, so here's another thing.
On the fourth time for when you're looking
to identify your POI,
you should mark out consecutive bearish candles, okay?
Most of the time, if there are like so many bearish candles,
right, just mark out the last candle,
or the one above it, from above it, okay?
But when you are looking for entries on 15 minute,
you should always take your entry
from the very last bearish candle
before the move to the upside that broke the structure.
So let's wait for price to come back into our POI,
into our entry zone.
Kaboom, that is our entry during London session.
So that is a plus point.
Put our stop right below this level, target one to two,
and I go back home.
And there you go, perfect, perfect move.
But you can see you can hold, it really depends on you guys.
I only look for one to two as I've said before
in my videos multiple times.
So yeah guys, I hope you guys understood
what I try to teach.
If you did not, feel free to ask questions,
and I'll try to answer them in my Discord server.